they do credit you with starting gangsta
rap is that accurate yeah cause like six
in the morning was considered the first
gangster rap people credit you with that
yeah and somehow the way i know it is
curtis blow has some sort of uh he's the
judge at some rap contest but it wasn't
a contest it was just the club and then
they just decided to have the contest
right and so i'm in there and my boy's
just like rap [ __ ]
i'm like that's curtis blow that's a
real rapper right you know and and then
i went up there and i said my little
lines and stuff and i remember what you
said i was cursing my ass off talking
about that's just doing my [ __ ] right
whatever the hell it happened yeah
whatever happened i got got hit man [ __ ]
hurt and burnt so i i uh
i won jeez a lot of guys were there and
you want
and i was like oh [ __ ] curtis blow a
real live rapper believes in me
maybe i maybe i can rap you know i never
took it serious and then after that day
i was like let me try to write some more
rhymes let me let me get a little bit
more serious with this hip hop was just
starting no one had ever bought a car
rapping so to me to rap was to go
backwards because we was making money
right so i'm like i don't [ __ ] these
rappers well we over here getting money
every day right yeah it's like a step
backwards monetarily at the time yes
they signed you to a record label nah
nah nah that not that didn't happen
after what happened was we i started to
make more music i started to hang around
with these cats from l.a called the new
york city spin masters doing house
parties and all that kind of stuff
and then i got in that movie called
breaking oh yeah yeah i was at a club
called the radio and i was in this movie
called breaking and
and they call me featured rap talker and
i did that and then i met a guy named
africa islam from new york city who was
a real hip-hop see to us west coast we
were trying to rap they were the real
you know and he believed in you yeah and
so you start making records i started
making records and and i got signed to
uh seymour stein signed me sire records
yes no kidding and seymour was like the
biggest record person i'd ever met he
had signed madonna right talking heads
yeah he had it all when seymour signed
me he said you sound like bob dylan so i
was like
really i knew who bob dylan was i took
that as a compliment and he says uh
do you understand this music uh you know
uh from trinidad and calypso music i'm
like no
he said well they're singing about the
problems over here just because you
don't understand it doesn't make it
dumb it just means you don't understand
it
in the same way i might not understand
everything you're rapping about it
doesn't make it make it wrong it just
means i don't understand it but i know
you are speaking to people so go make
your record